con un plantón frente a los altos
tribunales aquí en ciudad de guatemala
un grupo de trabajadores del diario el
periódico se manifestó hoy en contra del
gobierno de alejandro giammatei además
comparó al gobierno de guatemala con el
gobierno de daniel ortega en nicaragua y
no sólo por la persecución política y
encarcelamiento de diferentes dirigentes
de medios de comunicación sino también
por una de las medidas que hoy fue
tomada aquí en este país centroamericano
y fue la de haberle congelado todas las
cuentas bancarias que sostiene el
periódico con diferentes bancos
latinoamericanos a este medio de
comunicación que probablemente pueden
forzarlo a un colapso para que no pueda
llegar a cumplir con sus obligaciones
fiscales y parafiscales quienes pudo
detrás de esta decisión fue rafael curro
chiche el jefe de la fiscalía especial
en contra de la impunidad de guatemala
que recordemos en los días recientes fue
incluido en la lista en la lista del
departamento de estado de los estados
unidos en la cual curruchiche sale allí
su nombre por ser una de las personas en
guatemala de obstruir investigaciones de
actos de corrupción de altos
funcionarios del gobierno de llama 'the
y ahora por otra parte hoy que se tenía
previsto en la audiencia la primera
audiencia de imputación de cargos en
contra de josé rubén zamora el director
del diario el periódico pues esta cita
fue cancelada y diferentes organismos de
derechos humanos como incluso la
procuraduría de los derechos humanos de
guatemala denuncian que el hecho de que
se haya dilatado ésta
pues esta audiencia de imputación de
cargos resulta perjudicial para el
periodista porque permanecerá
encarcelado y está en detrimento de la
libertad de expresión aquí en guatemala